one active learning strategy that I use
in 595 are called mud cards and they are
a really easy activity to use anyone can
implement them and it's a really low
barrier so I like to introduce that
early in the class so that students can
see that it doesn't necessarily disrupt
the class flow it doesn't really take a
lot of prep it doesn't take a lot of
resources so a mud card is at at minimum
is an index card and at the end of every
class I ask them to write down on the
index card what they might want to know
more about what they're still confused
about or something that they found
particularly compelling or interesting I
asked them to specify that so that I
know if they just say active learning I
don't know whether they thought it was
really interesting or whether they
thought it was confusing so I asked them
to specify but we use we use that
because and then I'd also talked to them
about why it's so effective they're able
to anonymously identify what they
understood or what they're still
confused about I can go back to my
office afterwards I can look through the
cards I can sort them out really quickly
even in a large class and I've used them
in a class for of a hundred people
even though 595 is just around 15 and
generally speaking the cards fall in
three categories you get you get three
main problems and so you know that maybe
you didn't do a very good job of helping
students understand a particular topic
or that students are really interested
and want more information about
something I know that really easily
really quickly so I can make a decision
to either get more resources write
something up then I can post on on our
course website or I can come to class
the next time and say hey looks like
most of you are confused about X let's
talk a little bit more more about that
and I can prepare ahead of time and be
totally ready to go in with multiple
explanations or multiple examples of
whatever it is people are confused about
I looked over the mud some of the mud
cards we had from last time and there
were some really good questions some
really good points some ones to asked of
all those learning theories that we
discussed were equally valid they get
they get
targeted feedback based on what they
don't understand and it's really easy it
takes two minutes at the end of class I
have a colleague who calls them tickets
to leave meaning he doesn't let people
leave the class until they've handed him
an index card with something on it but
they're very very effective I believe
they were first used in the Aero aster
department here at MIT but they're but
they're used all over the place now and
they're extremely extremely effective
for instructors that are thinking about
using mud cards in their classes I would
say the biggest issue or the biggest
concern would be to make sure that you
use them early in the semester and that
you use them often if you use them one
day and then you don't use them for
another two weeks or even another week
students really won't get in the pattern
of filling them out and filling them out
thoughtfully and they won't see the
utility because you really need to come
back the next time with useful
information saying I I looked at these
cards I understand you don't get this
let me help you
and and that act really encourages
students to keep filling them out and
it's it's just a win-win for everyone